regarde la nouvelle qu'un voyant bien
d'arriver en ville mais c'est une gamine
son pouvoir grande eu tous les honneurs
tu peux lire en moi regardez moi dans le
fond des yeux seulement dépenser
honteuse celle que tu caches en full tu
as reçu ce dont tu doit maintenant
apprendre à l'apprivoiser
la famille royale a été massacrée cette
nuit il me faut la jeune clairvoyante
ma fille n'est pas encore prête nous
donnons un suspect pénètre son esprit
elle se doute de quelque chose
regardez-moi tarifs ou des yeux irrités
si elle comprend je saurai quoi faire
givi
nous avons tous les soldats et les
créatures du royaume à nos trousses il
n'y aura aucun survivant
elle doit 10
cachez-vous nous nous débarrasserons de
tous ceux qui auront les v ce n'est pas
en se cachant qu'on fera reculer le mal
simon pouvoir peut faire jaillir la
lumière alors il peut faire tomber un
royaume
il
entre les registres
ce boîtier de taille il n'y a qu'un seul
moyen de le savoir